[Music]
I'm sure many of you have heard of the
ALS A's ice bucket challenge for charity
that's right well this week has been a
lot of people demanding that I dump a
bucket of ice water on my head yeah
earlier today less enjoyment I decided
to accept the challenge take a look
hey there Internet Conan O'Brien here
now a lot of people have been calling me
out on this ALS ice bucket challenge I
just want to say I accept this sounds
like a really sweet deal apparently if I
get ice water pour it on my head
ALS will then pay me $100 that's a
pretty sweet deal let's do it wow that
was cold okay
ALS send the check to Conan O'Brien care
of the accountancy firm everybody hello
hello you don't get paid you get dunked
and pay okay this is a charity why would
I do both why would anyone we get a $100
cuz I get a lot of ice cold water poured
on it's a charity they're not gonna give
you do I don't get paid anything you
need a hundred times it you and really
need a bunch of sophix
hey well guess what psych ALS check this
out plastic ice was a balmy 92 degrees I
felt nothing in your
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow got a challenge people oh yeah
challenge I challenge Jimmy Carter Pele
Haley Joel Osment
Oh
[Applause]
of course I also I did make a donation
if you'd like to donate go to ALS a.org
/ donate it's a really good cause you
should do that a lot of good I think my
haircut the mo Howard from the Stooges
hair I had in that and that expression
that's how I should do this though every
night hair flat down just mad you wanna
show you'll get a show
you